every film has some reference to
technology whether it's Don Ameche using
the telephone is Alexander Graham Bell
but but this one technology was part of
the plot it drove it and when you heard
Bitcoin you thought wow this is a
different attitude toward embracing the
moment of technology too well Rick
wanted to make a movie kind of a modern
John Hughes movie and you can't make a
movie about high school today without
having all of the social networking and
you know technology that I know my kids
know about that I don't know about so
you know it was funny because there were
a lot of people who read the script to
say so this is a 90's movie like some a
lot of people thought it was a period
film because of the passion that these
that you know while the characters
exuded for 90s and 90s hip-hop but i
think that was obviously you know
showing that it's a movie for now and
you know i know from my high school
daughter there's no way she's not
functioning without you know all of the
social networking that she does nina
this film goes back and forth between
comedy and drama in the moment when
Malcolm pulls the gun just really makes
her head swivel 180 degrees how hard is
it to keep that nuance without letting
it tip too far one way that was an easy
other that we we talked me Forest
Whitaker and Rick talked about because
of the tonal shifts in the script and it
was a process of finessing the tones
making sure we don't go too far but at
the same time have an important message
that we all want to tell because these
kids from Inglewood California or any
other you know urban neighborhoods they
face these issues of crime drugs gangs
and and it's real it's a reality and I
remember some of the things that you
know early on in the script I was like
Rick these seem really extreme and he's
like well that's what I lived through I
grew up in Inglewood you know I've seen
all these crime in front of me happen in
front of me I've seen kids killed in
front of me so it's let's just be
truthful about it so it's about
balancing the tone during script level
and in during production he was able to
manage that so but it's very authentic
and truthful you shot this in 25 days
pretty much all in Inglewood what what
was
like to do that that's a tough shooting
schedule plus you're in inglewood what
kind of reaction were you getting from
the locals as you were out dude well we
actually shot all around Los Angeles and
we did several days in Inglewood is very
difficult to shoot in Inglewood because
of the releases that I had a sign so the
releases were so it was it was really
daunting how so it would be like please
sign away your life because if something
should happen to your talent your crew
and and we don't respond fast enough for
our cops our city or never responsible
for any harm or death that occurs it's
like signing something like that it was
crazy that even is that routine only for
the city of Inglewood city of a Compton
so so because they've you know
productions have run into problems in
certain cities because gang gang
relations you have to hire a gain
liaison you had to hire a gang relations
person you have to hire extra security
you have to up your insurance times five
you know there's so many elements that
really hinder it independent production
so we we made sure that we needed to
capture everything we need from
Inglewood the the landmarks that we
needed then we had a move out of
Inglewood and shoot in surrounding
cities we even shot some in van nuys but
then we're dealing in van nuys with
Mexican gangs so is it was a constant
issue of being aware of what was going
on being aware of our surroundings
making sure our actors were dressed
properly invests you know that they
weren't so that they weren't mistaken
for your real gangsters it was just a
lot of unawareness throughout you know
and so so David one of the things I
found most touching about this is that
it didn't slip into caricature the way
it might have been so easy well this was
so this was this was about Rick Allah so
much of this was about Rick and Malcolm
is very much like Rik he has a
photogenic photographic memory yes that
was funny ya know when he and how he
finessed that too was for ya nobody
listened this for him was very real you
know he on the movie that that he met
forest and did for him it was a director
for hire
rick is a writer director and and I
think he kind of felt like he needed to
get back to his roots so that's what he
did in a very authentic truthful way and
Patrick Milani just as you say an
outsider you're someone who comes here
from Italy how did the whole scenario
strike you that as you get into the the
mindset the neighborhoods that are
portrayed in this I actually have a lot
of books there's one book that was
called back in the days and the time
before crack that this was a
photojournalist who took these amazing
photos episode and it had been a period
also where I was looking a lot of 90s
music videos I don't know why but that
was happening and I also lived through
the 90s but again through Instagram
mostly I that was really helpful to get
what people actually dress like there
was a kid I inglewood height addresses
like Malcolm um but like you couldn't
lighter around Inglewood high as you
look kind of creepy very creepy and I
couldn't really friend them on Instagram
but I would follow them but I have a
binder of this big that would show Rick
of all these people that were obviously
I was following the people I were more
stylish were into music but um so was
that you know I'm a costume designer so
how it beyond the three principles how
did you use the clothes to define the
nature of the characters the other
characters like I found the character of
Quincy and his sister I you know I he
was Waring's kind of javon she clothes
and and and and Lily especially so I'm
blocking with her name Lily she only
mine who I had met which was 15 at ieast
on the wrong show i was i think was her
first job she was she sucks her between
a childish you know with her MDMA use so
i use terry cloth you know her whole
thing was mental kind of like a baby
onesies those except went and I guess
that Lee early you had to to deal with
this because Chanel had to vomit of
course in this so
I don't know how hard was it to edit all
that rice pudding she had a violent
quite a few times or she liked I end up
taking it in the face and that was
really him screaming yes it was the
natural reaction how much did the music
drive the film and the editing of it and
how did you sync those things together
the music was definitely the backbone of
the film it really gave it to life and
not only the 90s hip-hop cues that were
in there in the rap cues but pharrell's
original four songs were really brought
the characters out and they it was at
that point where we knew what was going
on in their minds and that you know and
the fact that all three of them actually
sang all the songs is is just amazing I
mean the last the last song in the movie
QC's voice is just so bold and and it
just it's awesome so you're hearing that
soundtrack in your head as you're
editing so yeah exactly what were some
of the most unexpected reactions that
any of you've gotten Nina to this
unexpected was because it was such a
labor of love and and it's a challenge
to make this film as you can see it's a
big movie to make it independently so
biggest surprises we kind of lost
perspective because it was so tough to
get it to Sundance and in having a
premier there where the audience
responded so beautifully and loved it
and laughed and standing ovation it was
it was worth it all that was the biggest
surprise for me and just happy I I
concur with that and then also the other
really nice surprise was when we asked
we didn't can a month ago and to see a
European audience predominantly white
audience embrace it the way it did and
give it a standing ovation and also how
the cast who was there were both
embraced and also kind of emboldened and
you know you just felt like you were
seeing the birth of the next generation
of of great movie stars that was really
a surprise and really kind of wonderful
to experience Nina when you did
fruitvale station the story of oscar
grant that young man who was shot by the
transit officer in San Francisco you
said you felt a lot of responsibility to
his family to his portrayal where's the
responsibility here to the community
that's or the even plural communities
being portrayed I think everything that
significant production force and I get
involved with how certain amount of
message that we want to tell our
audience and in this movie dope talks
about the racial issues perception that
that is prevalent in our country today
continues to be an issue and concern and
problem I mean of what just happened on
Thursday so we want to talk about
identity and also not to judge people by
it because you know Malcolm is is like
at the end when he broke the fourth wall
you know you're talking about what was
perception of a kid growing up in
Inglewood in a bad neighborhood so
hopefully people will take away that hey
this is a great fun movie but it really
has a social message about perception
and race